former u.s ambassador to ukraine bill
taylor he is currently vice president
russia and europe at the u.s institute
of peace mr ambassador good morning to
you
you spent three years as the u.s
ambassador to ukraine you were there as
recently as 2019 in a senior role in the
embassy so you know the country you know
the people what are you hearing
overnight
tonight i'm hearing that uh they are
determined they are
rattled they are concerned there is a
great concern about what president putin
has unleashed on them but they are
determined you heard from your reports
that ukrainians are going to stay and
fight
one of my friends said his sons
are already out there
with their weapons
they've been going to gun stores over
the last two weeks to buy weapons to be
able to defend themselves and their
homes
there have been the training that people
have signed up for young people have
gone out
and and this is a demonstration
of of ukraine's determination to to
resist this invasion
it's a country that knows conflict it's
been through conflicts before in its
recent history uh casualty numbers are
foggy at this hour but one ukrainian
official suggested upwards of 40
soldiers may be dead already uh many
more wounded
how's that number going to land in keeve
that's going to be that's going to be
just the beginning
this invasion is going to cost the lives
of military and civilian ukrainians
this is going to be tragedy this is
going to be a major tragedy it is also
going to cost the lives of many russian
soldiers ukrainian military is
very tough
it is very well equipped
it can bring
strong action against tanks coming in
the russian soldiers will die
they will go back to russian villages
and towns across that country and people
families who will have casualties
will ask why this is happening
there is no good reason so president
putin has not been able to give any
rationale any justification this is
unprovoked and unjustified and he will
have a hard time explaining this even to
his own people so the ukrainians will
resist they will experience these
casualties and it will further galvanize
the the country
ambassador you know how putin operates
from your experience there
is there any diplomatic avenue or is
putin not to be trusted because he's
proven that he's been lying all along
about having no intentions of invading
adrian it doesn't appear that president
putin has any
any issue any intent any possibility of
going to negotiations or diplomacy um he
has had that opportunity all this time
he's known
what the consequences would be he's
known what the consequences for his own
military will be
he has had the opportunity to take
another route and he has spurned it um
not only has he spurned it he's been
lying to the the world about what his
intentions are he said his people have
said he had no intentions to invade
ukraine that's clearly been a lie
ambassador you say this is a war crime
by president putin
in that case are sanctions really good
enough of a response by the u.s
sanctions need to be enormous sanctions
need to be
immediate sanctions need to be
international
and
we need to be recognizing
and and taking the steps
building the case
pulling the evidence of this war crime
this is unprovoked this is killing
civilians this is this is definitely a
war crime that president putin will will
pay for he will go down in history with
other war criminals of the last century
ambassador let's talk about the other
leader in this equation uh the president
of ukraine uh vladimir zielinski i've
been pointing out all morning that just
three years ago he was playing president
in a tv show about ukraine now he's in
the real thing and it is very real
indeed you met with him recently
is he up for this tony it's very
interesting he is up for this the short
answer is yes
president zelinski has stepped up
he's been in office for two years
he has been remarkably
disciplined remarkably resolute
remarkably firm
even remarkably calm in the lead-up to
to this invasion
he has stared down he has tried to stare
down president putin he's tried to
demonstrate that the ukrainian people
that he leads
are not going to compromise are not
going to bow to president putin he is
going to presidency is going to lead his
country so far he is standing up and
will rally the people and we will see
ukrainians fight the invaders
ambassador taylor thank you
thank you